are five statewide ballot questions on
your ballot this year
these would make changes to nevada's
constitution there is no question five
question six qualified by collecting
signatures and will have to pass voters
twice
it already passed comfortably back in
2018. question four took a different
route
passing through the legislative sessions
twice in 2017 and again in 2019
question four and question six would
both take a state law
and then enshrine it in the constitution
that would make it harder for
repeal of those laws later let's start
with question four
it would add eleven voting rights and
privileges currently known as the voters
bill of rights
that was passed in two thousand two the
voters bill of rights includes ability
to vote without being intimidated
threatened or coerced you are entitled
to vote
if on election day you are already in
line before the polls close
request assistance with voting if needed
receive
instructions on the use of voting
equipment the argument against question
four
in the secretary of state's digest calls
it a solution in search of a problem
and says federal laws already protect
those voting rights
now question six deals with the
renewable energy standards
it would raise nevada's renewable
portfolio standard
to 50 percent by 2030 through a stepped
process
again that is already in state law but
this would make it harder to repeal
in the future opponents said progress
continues to advance within the
renewable industry besieged with infancy
allowing outsiders to handcuff nevada is
misguided
the outsiders they are referring to is
billionaire tom steyer
whose pac put up nearly 10 million
dollars to collect the ballot signatures
for the
50 by 30 bill now if approved by voters
both questions 4 and question 6
would become part of the state's
constitution on the 24th of november
and if you still have questions about
how to vote we've got you covered
all you have to do is head to the
election 101 section on our website we
have all this ballot information
all of the election information eight
news now dot com and you'll find
everything you need to know
over the next couple of weeks